maxime le forestier bonsoir tué nominés
meilleure chanson avec né quelque part
victoires de la musique la semaine
prochaine le 19
qu'est ce que ça fait après toutes ces
années de soi retrouver sans doute sur
la scène de victoire la musique fait
plaisir ça veut dire
la chanson a plu aux gens
[Musique]
si on prend un peu ta carrière avec
regarde un peu tu étais 10 depuis san
francisco patrice le premier est ce que
tu crois pas que tu le voulais changer
le monde explique finalement cessé le
monde quitte à changer
oui ça c'est vrai que j'ai pas changer
du monde mais je pense tout le monde m'a
beaucoup changé non plus je pense que je
suis là c'est toujours un trouver un peu
utopiste pourrait un peu dingue comme ça
qui donne un peu sur un nuage et que je
me sens finalement très bien j'ai senti
comment que ça commence à bien marcher
qu'est ce qui s'est passé comment il a
vécu un moment vers le milieu des années
80 quand la fin des buts en 81 82 83 je
vous souhaite à toutes les salles
étaient mois peine qu'avant way
alors oui j'ai pris ça philosophe je me
suis dit que je devais arrêter de
chanter sur scène et puis quand les gens
auront envie à nouveau ben je chanterai
sur scène et finalement ça n'a pas pris
très longtemps ça a pris cinq ans c'est
pas très long tu as fait une traversée
du désert de cinq ans oh c'était un
désir avec des oasis quand même
ouais mais il ya quand même un moment où
tu as je suis pas le plus bas était sait
quoi faire le jour même un jour où tu ça
allait très mal quand même c'était quoi
le le centre du désert si tu veux pas
dire le font parce que c'est pas le fond
mais le centre du désert c'était comment
ce que si un jour
vraiment des coups de blues s'étaient
pas pour des raisons de métier c'était
pour d'autres raisons
c'est
et une histoire d'amour promouvoir
frankel blues
à chacun des hommes peuvent avoir fait
enquête blues mais j'ai jamais eu
vraiment le blues pour mon métier ça m'a
jamais vraiment à ce point préoccupante
a été une énorme star et quand tu es
arrivé dans une salle et que tu voyais
qu'elle était vendu à moitié ou au tiers
ça fait quand même bien de file un peu
le bourdon quand même si le bourdon ma
faim il faut chanter pour les gens qui
sont là aussi on commence on sent qu'il
12 parce qu'il ya la moitié de la salle
seulement avec eux on fait payer à ceux
qui sont venus fait que des gens soient
pas venu c'est pas très correct - il
et puis je sais pas c'est pas comme ça
que je prends les choses donc tu
toujours antimilitariste un peu moins
depuis que je suis allé à beyrouth
ouais et anti nucléaires un peu moins
depuis que j'ai rencontré des ingénieurs
qui ont expliqué les plus acides c'était
peut-être les centrales au fioul ou
alors tu penses quoi des mecs comme
renault belle marie toi un peu
enfin peut piquer ton credo finalement
trouvé mais c'est normal il ya
régulièrement le
la fonction discours d'adolescents pop
nantaise dallaire way est forcément
contestataires forcément remplit chaque
et chaque génération d'adolescents à son
grand frère j'ai rempli cette fonction
pendant un temps laure manaudou aussi
téléphone aussi
indochine aussi la renault vel mal
florent pagny est en train d'arriver
dans cette dans ce monde là c'est une
fac chanteur remplit une fonction avant
de sa vie un moment il faut changer de
fonction si comme les acteurs un homme
comme gabor a eu trois fonctions dans sa
vie il aura été jeune homme adulte et
puis vieillard tu préfères qui renault
goldman dure question
goldman est plus musicien et on opus
auteurs peut-être ils sont très variées
ensemble élémentaire ce serait pas mal
que renault écrivent pour musulmane ou
que goldman chante renonce à lutter et à
ses alliés une chose qui m'a beaucoup
surpris l'autre jour je t'ai vu dans une
émission de télévision ont parlé tout à
l'heure de la télévision et tu étais
chez patrick sébastien
oui l'étude était déguisé en mourousi
avec un costume trois pièces
les lunettes et une perruque et un
pantalon de pyjama comment je suis pas
trois mais toi la place de gens qui ont
aimé tes chansons qu'ils ont passé des
nuits entières sur des sons des platines
sur des pick-up dit on pas que pour eux
c'est terrible de voir faire ça à la
télé comme j'espère qu'ils se sont
mariés s'ils sont pas marrer c'est qu'on
est pas d'accord avec l'autre moi je
suis toujours dit que j'étais un
saltimbanque
si par un tenseur je suis pas un
philosophe sylviane mieux philosophe
heures etc et des bouquins mais toute
façon moi j'aimerais bien voir
glucksmann bernard henri lévy faire les
comptes chez sébastien ça me donnerait
les dramatiser un peu
l'ensemble s'apparente de faire un truc
comme ça non non non saltimbanques
non sérieusement non saltimbanques je
suis prêt à le faire quand il veut
me déguiser en mireille mathieu au
silence après tout on a vu sacha distel
hanche et là ça me fera toujours marrer
peut pas se déguiser moi j'ai pas mal
vécue au brésil
se déguiser au brésil se travestir c'est
normal le code dans la campagne
électorale moe j'étais en pleine
campagne électorale
les présidentiables devaient danser la
samba devant les caméras ce n'est pas
moi j'ai sérieusement ça m'a mis un peu
mal à l'aise parce que je me suis dit
finalement si maxime le forestier
n'avait pas été un chanteur
protestataires dans les fin des 60 des
plus de soixante dix
et s'il avait été agent d'assurances il
aurait c'est peut-être là c'est à dire
de bourousis ouais c'est à dire plus de
plus de cheveux si tu veux mais un peu
un peu gros comme ça avec un costume
trois pièces
ça mettait mal à l'aise trou peut-être
même que pour les victoires de la
musique je vais revêtir les régions tout
est à craindre était prêt à faire de la
pub par exemple tel que tu es parti je
vous dirai jamais fait j'en ai comme
musicien oui non mais je n'apparais
septembre mais en apparaissant je
suppose que je tourne fric oui bah tu
vois bien que tu as changé
la correction de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'institut
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux